- Somebody told me that you
had been to one of my shows
and I'm gonna tell you if that's true,
I am so glad that no one
told me you were there
because I would have
(bleep) a Christmas Turkey.
(laughing)
- Oh no.
No, when people come to my shows,
whom I adore.
I'm like you specifically can't tell me
because that's all I'm gonna
think about when I'm on stage.
- Oh no one ever told me,
not even after like no one ever told
and I literally, there is
a strict policy on my tour,
I don't want to know if anyone
in the audience is like,
I don't care how famous,
I don't want to know.
- No.
- 'Cause it makes me nervous
and I don't get nervous.
- So when you're singing
are you thinking of that
person the whole time.
- That's what I'm saying.
- I did the musical for jagged little pill
and a bunch of the
beautiful, beautiful singers,
performers, portrayers
came to see my shows
and unfortunately I'd
find out that they were
in the audience before I
was you know, and they're.
(laughing)
the most beautiful singers.
- That's so much pressure.
- And I just was like, oh God
and now I have to watch my pitch
and hit all the right notes
and just horrifying.
So I learned my lesson,
probably the more challenging way,
which is my whole show gets kerfuffled
if I know someone's in the audience
who's voice, or art I love.